it's Thursday night in Alabama and two
high schools have just finished playing
a game of football
offices from the Birmingham Police
Department approached the band director
and tell him to stop the music
warned that he'll be arrested if he
doesn't comply the lights to the stadium
are cut before Johnny Mims signals to
his band to wrap up
oh
[Applause]
police tried to arrest mums and a
scuffle breaks out
I did not swing him
[Applause]
Mims is tasin several times before being
taken away by police
[Applause]
in my opinion that the officers just got
a little bit uh too aggressive in the
situation I don't think it was a
situation where we could we wouldn't be
able to finish the last song and cut off
and and leave I'm not I'm not sure why
it needed to you know escalate past that
point Alabama state representative
Wonderland given is acting as mims's
attorney and has called the incident an
alarming abuse of police power
Mims has been charged with disorderly
conduct harassment and resisting arrest
Mike leppel Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera